Star Wars has been around for decades,
so it's a sad but inevitable reality that
many of the actors who have appeared in that
galaxy far, far away are no longer with us.
Here are a few faces from the franchise
you may not have realized passed away.
Admiral Ackbar had a pretty small role in
the original Star Wars trilogy — in fact,
he only appeared briefly in Return of the Jedi.
Even still, the character's appearance made
him a firm fan favorite, as did the iconic line
that has now passed on into pop culture legend.
"It's a trap!"
"Wow, Admiral Ackbar!"
Naturally, then, fans of Star Wars mourned the
unfortunate passing of Ackbar's voice actor,
Erik Bauersfeld, who died in 2016 at the age of
93. Interestingly, Bauersfeld once argued that
he thought of his movie roles as a secondary
career that he had accidentally stumbled into,
as opposed to his more solid work
as a radio producer. He once wrote:
"The voice work I did in movies was
accidental. I was working with Randy
Thom on radio dramas at his technical
quarters at Lucasfilm. One day Ben Burtt,
sound designer for Star Wars, came by and asked
if I would audition for a voice in the movie."
Bauersfeld also voiced Bib Fortuna, one of Jabba
the Hutt's associates, and he returned to the role
of Admiral Ackbar in The Force Awakens, which
released just months before he passed away.
As he dies in the opening hour of the film,
Uncle Owen can be considered a pretty minor
Star Wars character in the grand scheme of things
— but his death is the primary call to arms that
sets Luke Skywalker off on his hero's journey.
So in a weird way, Owen is actually one of the
movie's most important characters — making actor
Phil Brown one of the story's pivotal players.
Sadly, Brown passed away in 2006 at the age of 89.
Even though he was well-known when Star Wars was
made, he'd faced plenty of hardships as an actor.
In the 1950s, Brown was caught up in Senator
Joseph McCarthy's communist trials, and was
actually blacklisted because he refused to comply
with the House Un-American Activities Committee's
demands to name communists in Hollywood. He denied
being a communist himself, but was still
forced to move to London to continue acting.
As it happened, George Lucas was filming
in London at the same time and needed a
local actor with an American accent — so
he brought Brown on board. Not long after,
Brown was with Lucas in Tunisia, filming
A New Hope's early scenes on Tatooine.
A powerhouse English actress, Shelagh Fraser died
in 2000 at the age of 79. She had played a small
but memorable role in A New Hope, as Luke's aunt
Beru. The character dies early on in the story,
so Fraser was unable to contribute a
lot to the film, but just like Lars,
Beru's death spurs Luke into action, driving
his character arc through much of the trilogy.
And even though her role in Star Wars is small,
some would argue that she's indirectly responsible
for Luke becoming the hero he is. At a New York
Comic-Con panel, author Meg Cabot argued that very
case, suggesting that Aunt Beru's kindness and
caring for Luke helped him overcome the Dark Side
and defeat the Empire. It also helped him find
the compassion to look for the good left in Darth
Vader, without whom he never would have stopped
Emperor Palpatine. So yeah, nice work, Aunt Beru.
Drewe Henley appeared in the Star Wars
franchise as Red Leader, the pilot who
led Luke's squadron in the strike against the
Death Star at the climax of A New Hope. Sadly,
he was accidentally credited as "Drewe Hemley" at
the end of the film, but hey, he at least managed
to squeeze in a post-mortem appearance in Rogue
One, thanks to the power of archive footage.
In the first film, Red Leader actually nearly
destroys the Death Star. He launches his torpedoes
at the exhaust port, but his aim is slightly off.
Not long after his miss, his ship is destroyed,
and the poor guy is subsequently killed.
Henley was a well-respected actor when he
was cast in A New Hope, but was forced to
retire not long after the film was released
due to his struggles with bipolar disorder.
After working through his mental illness,
he settled down to run a bed and breakfast with
his wife. Henley died in 2016 at the age of 75.
Anakin Skywalker has been played by multiple
actors across the Star Wars franchise,
but when his deformed, weary face is
revealed in Star Wars: Return of the Jedi,
that's classically trained actor Sebastian
Shaw playing the role. He also portrayed
Anakin's Force ghost at the end of the
original version of Return of the Jedi,
before being replaced by Hayden
Christensen in subsequent releases.
Shaw was mostly known as a stage actor outside
of Star Wars fandom. He was a member of the Royal
Shakespeare Company, where he often played lead
or featured roles. He was also a Broadway veteran,
and was well known for taking on parts
in daring and controversial plays.
Lucas choosing to digitally replace
Shaw with Christensen in Return of
the Jedi sparked some controversy at the
time, but Star Wars fans will still never
forget the reveal of Darth Vader's face.
Shaw passed away in 1994 at the age of 89.
Jason Wingreen didn't actually appear in the Star
Wars films in person, but his voice brought one
of the saga's most iconic villains to life.
Wingreen was the original voice of Boba Fett,
the intergalactic bounty hunter who tracks
down Han Solo during The Empire Strikes Back.
Wingreen was a well-known television
actor when he auditioned for Star Wars,
having appeared in a number of different
shows throughout the '60s, '70s and '80s.
He originally auditioned for the role of Yoda,
but lost out on the role and was cast as Boba
Fett instead — and only recorded four lines
for the final film. He's not even credited,
and it wasn't until the year 2000 that the public
discovered who had voiced the villain. Still,
it's a testament to Wingreen's talent
that Boba Fett became such a massively
popular character nonetheless. Wingreen
passed away in 2016 at the age of 95.
You may never have seen Kenny Baker's face
or heard his voice in a Star Wars film,
but it's a fair bet you still know him —
for most of the movies in the franchise,
he portrayed one of sci-fi's
most iconic characters: R2-D2.
R2-D2 wasn't a puppet or an animatronic like so
many other creatures in the Star Wars universe.
Instead, there was an actor inside that
droid. Baker was only 3 foot 8 inches,
so he could fit inside the chassis used for
filming, and he's the one responsible for crafting
much of R2-D2's "personality." When Baker passed
away in 2016 at the age of 81, StarWars.com wrote:
"Whether it was the slow turn of
Artoo's dome to convey suspicion or
nervous wobbles signifying fear, Baker
made a robotic being seem very human."
While Baker played the droid in
all three original films and two
prequels, he also played an Ewok
[EE-wok] in Return of the Jedi.
Peter Cushing was a massive star when
he was cast as Grand Moff Tarkin in
A New Hope. He also brought an
immediate gravitas to the film,
oozing menace and calm and somehow coming off
every bit as intimidating as Darth Vader himself.
"Charming, to the last."
Before appearing in A New Hope, Cushing was an
icon in horror cinema. He appeared in many of
the Dracula and Frankenstein films of the '50s and
'60s, and also portrayed Sherlock Holmes in a few
movie adaptations. After a long and illustrious
career, Cushing passed away in 1994 at the age of
81. Despite this, however, he technically reprised
his role as Tarkin in Rogue One: A Star Wars
Story, even though the film came out over 20 years
after his death. Cushing was recreated in the film
with state of the art CGI, nearly climbing out
of the uncanny valley in the process. Nearly.
Even though Obi-Wan Kenobi died in A New Hope,
Alec Guiness appeared in the other films of the
original trilogy, thanks to the power of the
Force. His casting lent some credibility to the
original film, but he also infamously viewed the
story as — in his words — "fairy tale rubbish."
Guinness was a hugely famous actor when he
signed on for George Lucas' space opera. He'd
won an Oscar for The Bridge on the River Kwai
and had starred in classics such as Lawrence of
Arabia and Doctor Zhivago. And while many of the
leading actors in Star Wars are big names now,
they weren't at the time, making Guinness by far
the biggest star in the movie in 1977. But why did
he join the project if he hated the material?
Well, there were a couple of reasons. First,
he thought the moral of the story was
admirable enough. Second, he wouldn't have
to do any publicity for the film. And third, the
studio offered him a massive salary. Of course,
he ignored any fan mail he received about
Star Wars, and hated discussing his role
as Obi-Wan. Sir Alec Guinness passed
away in the year 2000 at the age of 86.
One of the most prolific actors in the Star
Wars franchise, Christopher Lee's career spans
over 250 roles over the length of his career.
Lee is absolutely one of the gods of geekdom,
and has graced several of Hollywood's most
notable franchises. Here, he portrayed Count
Dooku in two of the prequel films, Attack of
the Clones and Revenge of the Sith. Lee became
a star due to his many appearances in the Hammer
Horror Dracula franchise, where, funnily enough,
he frequently collaborated with another Star Wars
alum: Peter Cushing. Lee's imposing figure and
commanding voice made him perfectly suited
to playing the villain, which helped him a
great deal in arguably his biggest ever film
role: playing Saruman in The Lord of the Rings.
A man of many talents, Christopher Lee
also released a number of heavy metal
albums when he was in his 80s and 90s. He was
also knighted, served in the Second World War
as a member of the RAF and was attached to
the British Army's Long Range Desert Group,
the precursor of the modern-day SAS. He
passed away in 2015 at the age of 93.
Despite never having showed his face on-screen in
Star Wars, Peter Mayhew quickly became one of the
saga's most iconic characters. His performance
as Chewbacca helped bring a sense of real
humanity to a character where many other actors
could easily have been lost beneath the mask.
"Laugh it up, fuzzball."
Mayhew was a hospital orderly
when he auditioned for Chewbacca,
and even kept that job until after Return of the
Jedi was released. The 7 foot 3 inch actor then
essentially made his living off the role for
the rest of his life, attending conventions as
a fan favorite star for decades. He eventually
reprised the role in 2015's The Force Awakens.
Nearly everyone who worked with Mayhew on
the Star Wars franchise had nothing but
kind things to say about him. After his death
in April 2019, Mark Hamill wrote on Twitter:
"He was the gentlest of giants. A
big man with an even bigger heart
who never failed to make me smile, and
a loyal friend who I loved dearly. I'm
grateful for the memories we shared and I'm
a better man for just having known him."
Peter Diamond was more of a stuntman
and a coordinator than an actor,
with almost 250 roles in the "stunts" category on
his IMDB page. However, he had a variety of small
roles in the original Star Wars trilogy, and he
had a large impact on several memorable scenes.
Some of the Star Wars roles Diamond took
on include A'Koba, the Tusken Raider who
attacks Luke Skywalker, and Garouf Lafoe,
the guy who rats out Luke and Obi-Wan to the
stormtroopers at the Mos Eisley cantina.
He also appeared as various helmeted or
background characters in the trilogy, often
when those roles called for dangerous stunts.
His other contribution to the original
trilogy came from his role as the stunt
coordinator. He actually created two
different styles of lightsaber combat
used by the films' Sith and Jedi. Diamond
passed away in March 2004, at the age of 74.
According to the credits of The Empire Strikes
Back, John Hollis played "Lando's Aide," as he's
not actually given a name in the film. However,
many Star Wars fans know him as Lobot, the cyborg
who helps Lando Calrissian fight back against the
stormtroopers so the heroes can escape Cloud City.
According to some deeper Star Wars lore, Lobot
originally used his cybernetic enhancements
to augment his intelligence. However,
during a mission gone wrong with Lando,
Lobot was injured and lost the aspects
of his mind that made him human. So now,
he's essentially a computer operating
a human body. His unique cybernetics
allow him to have a direct connection
with Cloud City's computer system.
Hollis appeared in several other popular films,
including most of the Christopher Reeves
Superman movies, Flash Gordon, and For Your
Eyes Only. After a 40-year acting career,
Hollis passed away in 2005 at 77 years old.
In A New Hope, Jek Porkins was a
part of Luke's Red Squadron during
the assault on the Death Star. He
flew as Red 6, and unfortunately,
he couldn't contribute much to the battle.
His ship malfunctioned early in the fight,
and unable to maneuver, he was
quickly shot down by Imperial forces.
Besides his role as Porkins in A New Hope, William
Hootkins also had roles in movies like Flash
Gordon, Raiders of the Lost Ark, and Superman IV.
Outside of Star Wars, his most well-known role
probably came in 1989's Batman, where he played
corrupt Gotham Police Lieutenant Max Eckhardt. He
was also a prolific voice actor, as he frequently
lent his voice to radio plays and audio books.
Hootkins died from pancreatic
cancer in 2005. He was 57 years old.
Alex McCrindle played a very small role in
A New Hope, but he was actually the first
actor to speak one of Star Wars' most famous
quotes. McCrindle played General Dodonna,
who tells the Rebels their plan of attack when the
Death Star is approaching. After explaining that
the Death Star's only weak point is a tiny exhaust
port, some of the Rebel pilots express concern.
Luke Skywalker speaks up that the target isn't
impossible, which prompts this line from Dodonna:
"Then man your ships, and
may the Force be with you."
The quote is often mistakenly
attributed to Obi-Wan Kenobi,
who never actually says that line in A New Hope.
Alex McCrindle was known more
for television than film,
and A New Hope is one of the only big name films
to his credit. He died in 1990 at the age of 78.
Jack Purvis was one of Hollywood's
most well-known little person actors,
so it's no surprise that George Lucas cast him in
more significant alien roles across his original
trilogy. Purvis actually played three different
characters in the three original Star Wars films.
He appeared as the head Jawa in A New Hope,
the chief Ugnaught in The Empire Strikes Back,
and Teebo the Ewok in Return of the Jedi. He
was no stranger to the entertainment scene,
as Purvis had been in a touring musical
group with fellow Star Wars actor Kenny
Baker. The duo traveled to many bars and
clubs with their musical-comedy show.
Purvis also appeared in several other
memorable films, mostly in the 1980s,
such as Time Bandits, Willow, Brazil, and
Labyrinth. Purvis died at the age of 60 in 1997.
Larry Ward might not be the most famous Star
Wars actor with only two movies to his credit,
A New Hope and Return of the Jedi, but he loaned
his voice to two of Star Wars' most memorable
baddies. In the original film, he played the
voice of the notorious bounty hunter, Greedo.
"Jabba wanin cheeco. Wa rush anye
katanye wanaruska, heh heh heh."
And in Return of the Jedi,
he provided the dialogue for everybody's
favorite space gangster, Jabba the Hutt.
Even more important than giving the giant slug
his voice was helping to develop the entire
language he spoke. The foundation for Huttese
was laid down by sound designer Ben Burtt. He
based the language on Quechua, the language
of a group of indigenous Peruvians. Burtt
played Quechua recordings for Ward, then told the
actor to improvise dialogue that sounded like it.
Ward passed away in 2007 at the age of 63.
Andrew Jack contributed to the Star Wars
franchise in multiple ways. Fans might
recognize him as Caluan Ematt, a major in the
Resistance forces in The Force Awakens and a
general in The Last Jedi. He was also the voice
of Moloch in Solo: A Star Wars Story. However,
Jack's real contribution to Star
Wars came as a dialect coach.
Jack helped many of the actors in the later Star
Wars films perfect their accents. As TMZ noted,
it's very likely that Jack taught John
Boyega how to hide his British accent
for the part of Finn. He also
helped the actors learn to speak
fictional languages. As original Solo
director Christopher Miller explained
"We asked him to teach Alden [Ehrenreich]
to speak Shyriiwook. I'll always remember
listening to them gargle-roar
at each other back and forth."
"Yeah, I speak a little, now just
listen to me you (Chewbacca noises)."
"(Chewbacca noises)"
Outside of the Star Wars franchise, Jack worked
on accents in some of the biggest films ever made,
including the Avengers franchise
and the Lord of the Rings series.
In March 2020, Andrew Jack passed away
from complications due to COVID-19.
Richard LeParmentier played Admiral Motti,
the man who dared mock Vader's Force practices
during a meeting between several Imperial
officers in A New Hope. Confident that the
Death Star will wipe the Rebels from the
history books, Motti dismisses Vader when
the Sith Lord compares the Death Star's
power unfavorably to that of the Force.
"Your sad devotion to that ancient religion has
not helped you conjure up the stolen data tapes."
That's what causes Vader to demonstrate
the Force-choke technique. Motti later
directs the Death Star toward Alderaan and
leads Imperial operatives in blowing it up.
LeParmentier relished the role, once
proudly describing Motti as "the only
Imperial officer who ever stood up to
Darth Vader." The actor even started up
a now-defunct Motti fan site and reprised
the character in a 2012 Xbox commercial
that recreates his most famous scene. Had
the 66-year-old not passed away in 2013,
he and other Star Wars actors would've
played their roles once again in Motti Now,
a fan project by LeParmentier that went through
various permutations, including a comic book.
Things might've gone better for the Empire if
General Tagge had been involved in overseeing
the Death Star, rather than Darth Vader and
Grand Moff Tarkin. Played by Don Henderson,
Tagge is in the scene where Vader chokes
Motti, cautioning his fellow Imperial
officers to take the Rebels' theft of the
Death Star schematics seriously. Tagge also
expresses dismay when Tarkin announces the
Imperial Senate's dissolution, but neither
Motti nor Tarkin pay much heed to the heaping
helping of common sense Tagge flings at them.
While Star Wars gained Henderson
recognition outside of the U.K.,
Henderson himself admitted to Star Wars: The
Official Magazine that his involvement had
slipped his mind until he saw it with his son
in the movie theater. That didn't stop him from
having a healthy acting career that lasted nearly
three decades, particularly gaining acclaim and
attention in the U.K. for portraying quirky law
enforcement officer George Bulman in The XYY Man.
His career also involved a notable role in Doctor
Who. Henderson died on June 22nd, 1997, just a few
months after his character returned to theaters
in the Special Edition version of A New Hope.
Though not a major character, you'll likely
remember Eddie Byrne's Commander Willard,
the first fellow member of the Rebellion
whom Leia interacts with on Yavin IV when
she finally arrives. Though a small part,
Willard actually does do something fairly
important in the film; namely having the
Death Star plans extracted from R2-D2 so
the Rebels can figure out how to
attack the moon-shaped station.
Byrne was no stranger to two of the higher-profile
actors in A New Hope. In 1966's Island of Terror,
Byrne, portraying Dr. Reginald Landers, seeks
out help from pathologist Brian Stanley,
played by Grand Moff Tarkin actor Peter
Cushing. And in the 1959 movie The Scapegoat,
Byrne plays a friendly bartender who helps
Sir Alec Guinness' character become better
acquainted with his physical double, also played
by Guinness. Sadly, the chances of the three
actors appearing in another film together ended
when Eddie Byrne passed away on August 21st, 1981.
Given how many characters in Star Wars wear armor
or are aliens, there are plenty of actors from the
saga whose faces you never see. Such is the case
with Des Webb, who is the Wampa that Luke and
his tauntaun run into while making the rounds on
Hoth. While Webb himself isn't visible to viewers,
as he's inside a big hairy costume, fans of the
unaltered original trilogy may recall that the
Wampa doesn't appear on-screen quite as much
before 1997. Blame Webb's costume, which was
just too cumbersome for the actor to pull off
all the Wampa's feats. The Special Edition
version of Empire added more Wampa footage,
with Howie Weed stepping into a new costume.
Webb's acting roles were few and
low-key. Interestingly, however,
the final film he's credited in, Morons from
Outer Space, has an intro that emulates the
scene in A New Hope where Darth Vader's Star
Destroyer first appears. Webb died on May 21st,
2002, five days after Attack of
the Clones made its U.S. debut.
The man in the battered Mandalorian armor in
both Empire and Return of the Jedi is Jeremy
Bulloch. As Bulloch explained to Sci-Fi Central,
he was actually juggling his days shooting as Boba
Fett with his evening job as a theater actor. The
packed schedule didn't affect his enthusiasm for
the role, though he admitted to StarWars.com
that the costume wasn't exactly the coziest.
Bulloch being the original Boba Fett is
well-known to the Star Wars faithful,
but perhaps not as common knowledge is the fact
that Bullock appears unmasked in Revenge of the
Sith as Captain Colton, who takes several
of the heroes to Coruscant to figure out
why Clone Troopers are killing Jedi. He's
also Empire lackey Lieutenant Sheckil,
who seizes Leia when she warns Luke that
Vader's been expecting the young Jedi.
Bulloch appeared in several features, and in
fan films afterward in roles that paid homage
to his iconic character. He passed away from
Parkinson's complications on December 17th, 2020.
Irish actor Ray Stevenson first ventured
into a galaxy far, far away in Star Wars:
Rebels as the voice of Mandalorian
Gar Saxon, leader of the Mandalorian
Super commandos. He later reprised the
role in the Clone Wars animated series.
Marvel fans might recognize him as
Frank Castle in Punisher: War Zone,
or the MCU's Volstagg. His roles also
extended into other popular series
on both the big and small screens, like
Dexter, the Divergent series, and Vikings.
Stevenson's reinsertion into the Star Wars
franchise came posthumously. He passed away
on May 21st, 2023, only three months before the
debut of Ahsoka, where he portrays the mysterious
Baylan Skoll. While Stevenson is not alive to see
fans' reaction to Ahsoka, he's expressed great
joy in taking part, telling Screen Rant Plus he
considers the series "sprinkled with pixie dust."